hi I'm Matt Welch am with my coop and
Nick Gillespie of declaration of
independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America we're
here at ask a libertarian day next one
up on Twitter zack from cali gary
johnson or rampal had a lot like that my
answer is I didn't realize that it come
down to a final two and that we had to
make a decision one way or the other
it's a strange sort of libertarian
parlor game right now to figure out
which one you want to not support I
don't necessarily understand the impulse
I don't think that people are going
through the same kind of gymnastics
between Rick Santorum and michele
bachmann right now for example so i
think the best way to think about it is
that ron paul is on a long term
educational philosophical project
running for president is part of that
Gary Johnson comes from a more kind of
cost-benefit analysis pragmatic point of
view they each bring something very
important to the table I don't expect to
be voting in the Republican nomination
process so i won't have a vote but i
like gary johnson because of his
management experience and i think he
cuts a great figure and really speaks to
a to the future in a fascinating way and
I can't help but thank Ron Paul for
everything he's done for really getting
the libertarian message out there and
really spreading it around and also
showing that the Internet is massively
powerful as an organizing and
fundraising tool we've got a related
question from Jeffrey Bala among the
2012 field of Republican candidates not
counting Ron Paul or governor gary
johnson who is the least bad candidate
declared or possible I got to say nobody
and you know that's that's from the gut
and it's also from like my passing
resemblance or by passing a quaint
reality there's nobody out there what
I'm looking for in a candidate is simply
somebody who will say no to the warfare
state no to the social welfare state for
middle-class and rich people and
somebody who is going to get the economy
going by getting the government out of
the
economy sadly I look on the horizon and
I don't see anybody there fill in the
space